alain coudray bonjour
bonjour
bonjour à tous et merci de m'accueillir
eh bien merci à vous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation on le disait la
préfecture maritime a autorisé à partir
d'aujourd'hui le forage d'une nouvelle
zone de la baie de saint brieuc une
annonce qui a fait réagir les pêcheurs
qui vous fait réagir pourquoi
pour une raison c'est que ils ont
commencé en mai et ils ont essayé de me
le faire des trous le premier y en a qui
s'est affaissée alors certes pas de
résultats à la fondation n'est pas mise
le deuxième ils ont cassé le matériel à
une pollution de 45 kilomètres carrés et
ils sont partis se faire réparer et les
autorités maritimes leur ont donné une
zone au nord où le travail est assez dur
assez durs pour comment pour qu'ils
étaient quand même
de façon à ce qu'ils voient et ceux ci
peuvent causer ce qui n'est pas le cas
non plus et au bout de dix jours de
travaux ils ont encore casser du
matériel effet une petite pollution
effet il demande de changement de zone
ce qui faisait une deuxième zone ils
demandaient une troisième est là
jeudi dernier on a eu une haute
à noter arrêté comme quoi il aucune
ouvrait encore une zone à une zone
aujourd'hui parce que les deux les deux
forage qui leur avaient été deux
autorisés à faire la semaine dernière
ils en sont toujours pas terminés
depuis
vendredi ils ont ils avaient trois trous
de 3 forages trois diamètres à faire sur
25 m y'en a un qui était terminée
inquiété à 15 m et 1,15 euro au rapport
d'hier soir il ya 25 mètres qui fait
lotir eia il doit y avoir 20 mètres de
fait et l'autre toujours 0 et voilà ils
demandent encore user de se déplacer
d'une fois ça veut dire ils sont en
train de faire un mitage tout le tout
heureux
tout au long du parc
surtout que ces bateaux là doivent
partir au mois d'octobre les 6 zones là
on aurait pu retourner pêcher cet hiver
voilà pourquoi on est en colère et nous
on en a marre ils sont incapables de
nous deux percées et on
s'obstine à vouloir essayer et l'état de
dit absolument rien alors le vice
président de lamballe terre et mer dont
l'huile est favorable projet éolien il
s'est exprimé hier dans les colonnes du
télégramme et pour lui c'est bien le
changement climatique et non les
éoliennes qui vont impacter durablement
et fortement la baie de saint brieuc
qu'est ce que vous lui a répondu ce
matin
on va je lui réponds commun ses
collègues de bâle à mulhouse en marche
puisque dont fait partie que que nous
sommes nous en côtes d'armor où on est
neuf cents bateaux 900 marins ce qui
fait de 3000 emplois
qui fait 3000 emplois alors il va vous
répondre je paie réponse commence à les
connaître ils vont nous répondent oui
vont nécessiter on est en défaut de
l'électricité
on y donne un pays qui s'appelle la
france si tous les régions françaises
pour lise électricité et
en or et romane ou en bretagne on
nourrit les gens les pêcheurs on pêche
du poisson et à nos amis les
agriculteurs ils font
ils produisent des légumes et en avons
de nombreux noms de nombreuses de
nombreuses usines agroalimentaires en
france que chacun fasse un travail 1er
août et si on a besoin en électricité et
petits français qui met dans la pensée
si ils peuvent nous faire le fait citer
et justement raisonnement moi et j'ai eu
alors justement très concrètement sur
votre activité de pêche c'est parc
éolien ils ont quel conséquent c'est à
dire que vous pouvez plus aller aller
pêcher sur zone
alors les conséquences sont les
conséquences on va les avoir tout de
suite voilà si tout de suite on s'en
aperçoit déjà bien moins de poissons ont
roulé les fesses comme la seiche la
seiche bien sûr vu qu'ils viennent se
reproduire ou les lanières cette année
la seiche à nana ne va pas atterrir et
va atteindre ont trop large et il faudra
les chercher au large plus tard
là nous sommes en pleine reproduction de
la petit saint jacques un l'impact sur
sur la pollution la pollution on va
connaître le bain
bientôt pouvoir fait qu'on va voir les
résultats de ce que nous ont faits
maison c'est-à-dire les côtes des
collecteurs voilà mes lecteurs et on
verra si si elle
a besoin de laver et voilà c
est est ce que vous entendez aujourd'hui
mener des actions il y en a eu on s'en
souvient pour vous vous opposez à ce
parc éolien à ce que vous avez au moins
des moyens juridiques aujourd'hui pour
vous y opposer
avec aujourd'hui on
n'a plus que le moyen juridique
parce que comment aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus bouger à des coraux dès qu'il ya un
mouvement qui était prévu tout le monde
est sur écoute que mon récit est suivie
et des eaux on espère que le lot on en a
peur de nous je pense parce que comment
le jour vous alors à vraiment se
fâcher parce que moi j'ai eu quelques
manifestations mais là
on veut pas que
l'on veut pas embêtés et les français
qui s'ils ont besoin de rouler si on
bleuté route voilà c'est pas c'est pas
le truc nous re nous on veut défendre
notre métier et leur petit lit sur l'eau
alors c'est très difficile de le faire
on pourrait la beaucoup de journées on
pourrait faire une salle mais il a dans
mr c'est pas facile le problème est là
c'est on a c'est pas facile ça si je
veux de manifester en mer bon c'est un
ter et on leur fera peut-être mais pour
le moment la seule chose cohérent on
souhaite c'est que vraiment pas notre
sol soit aussi soit aussi dur que ce que
nous mais la tête et puis qu'elle ne
puisse parfaire leur leur chantier c'est
tout vous avez les seuls pour conclure
vous avez le soutien de la population
locale elle est dans quel état d'esprit
ce qu'elle est partagée ou au contraire
elle vous soutient
une grande partie de la pollution locale
est avec nous une partie un peu et
malheureusement quelques politiques
aussi
aimé
les politiques qui sont qui sont qui
sont avec nous c'est plutôt un
c'est pas la majorité voit c'est pas la
majorité ces jeunes de l'opposition et
autres prêts automatiquement il vole le
pouvoir que
devant monsieur macron ils ont pas
l'impression qui pourrait avoir merci
beaucoup en tout cas alain coudray
d'avoir répondu à nos questions suivra
l'évolution de près ici à rt france je
le rappelle vous êtes président du
comité départemental des pêches des
côtes d'armor